the FBI inquiry that delayed a
confirmation vote on Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh is now finished
the much-anticipated report on the
sexual assault allegations against
Cavanaugh was delivered overnight to the
Senate where the final vote is now
planned for Saturday The Wall Street
Journal reports the White House found
the FBI report provided no corroboration
of the allegations against Cavanaugh
which he denies many potential witnesses
complained they were not questioned
including Cavanaugh's most public
accuser Christine Blasi Ford Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill where the FBI
report is under high security Nancy good
morning where is it well it is in a room
in the basement of the Capitol Norah
that is normally reserved for high
stakes security briefings instead there
will be just one copy that senators can
view starting this morning that's to cut
down on leaks and they're going to want
to view it today because the Senate's
Republican leader has set up a
procedural vote for tomorrow with a
final confirmation vote expected on
Saturday there'll be plenty of time for
members to review and be briefed on the
supplemental material before a Friday
cloture vote Republicans and Democrats
will take turns viewing the highly
anticipated FBI findings which will
summarize interviews with at least five
high school friends of Brett Kavanaugh
and Christine Blasi Ford the goal to
shed light on Ford's accusation that
Cavanaugh pinned her down and groped her
in 1982 if I were king for a day I'd say
it needs to be made public as of
yesterday the FBI had not interviewed
Ford or Cavanaugh themselves along with
more than a dozen people proposed by
Ford's lawyers and overnight The New
Yorker reported that frustrated
witnesses wanting to speak to the FBI
about other allegations against
Cavanaugh were ignored
Debra Ramirez who alleges Kavanaugh
exposed himself to her at a Yale party
was interviewed by the FBI but she told
The New Yorker people who were key to
corroborating my story have not been
contacted I feel like I'm being silenced
Cavanaugh has denied all the claims
against him how did you get home I don't
remember
how'd you get there I don't remember
meantime the White House is working to
tamp down a
fire caused by the president's comments
about Ford Tuesday night
upstairs Downstairs where was I don't
know but I had one beer
his aides insist President Trump wasn't
mocking Ford just relaying information
she's been treated like a Faberge egg by
all of us beginning with me and the
president he's pointing out factual
inconsistencies but that's not how some
senators saw it were just playing drive
his mockery of dr. Ford last night in
Mississippi was wrong but it doesn't
really surprise anyone last night
Nebraska Republican Ben Sasse praised
Judge Cavanaugh's record but said he had
advised the White House to pick a woman
for the Supreme Court I will say that I
urged the president back in June and
early July to make a different choice
before he announced this nomination in a
statement Ford's attorney said that any
FBI probe that doesn't include an
interview with dr. Ford quote cannot be
called an investigation and they say
they are quote profoundly disappointed
republicans argue that Ford had her say
when she testified here on Capitol Hill
last week yeah yeah a lot of differing
opinion on that particular part thank
you very much Nancy